التوقع ان نقولها ربما بشكل واضح ولكن اذا
ما فشل في الجوله الثانيه اعتقد انه لا
يستطيع البقاء على راسي حزب الشعب
الجمهوري كرئيس له ومن ثم ايضا تعرفون ان
هؤلاء كانوا مرشحين يعني المتحالفين كانوا
مرشحين ليكونوا نواب الرئيس في حال فوزهم
واعتقد ان تلك الاحزاب احزاب المعارضه
ايضا جميعا كل
تتاثر سلبا
اما حزب ربما
نعم الوطن
حسب
السعاده لم يسهم كثيرا في واقع الامر في
حزب الشعب الجمهوري وايضا كانت مشاركه
الحزب الجيد مشاركه اجباريا نوعا ما وليس
عن رضا لذلك سنجد ان هناك تغييرات وربما
تقلبات مختلفه في تلك هذه الاحزاب
ومن ناحيه اخرى كما قلت قبل قليل وامام من
ناحيه الحزب الحاكم ايضا
الان الرئيس
اردوغان كذلك
الان اصبح يحتاج الى اصواته حزب الحركه
القوميه فبالتالي حتى ولو فاز فانه لا
يستطيع ان يقوم بانتاج السياسات مستقله
وخاصه حيال المشكله الكرديه وسينصت الى
ايضا التوجهات القوميه نظرا لارتباطه
وحاجته الى الحركه القوميه وكذلك من حيث
العلاقات مع اوروبا وايضا ربما تركي
ستنتهج سياسه التوتر اكثر في العلاقات مع
اوروبا